so I thought that I would you know ask
some questions in the past about to
bring things out of that communal land
is worthless I can't do that I'm going
to do about the east place in class
right now and the way the French talk
about the United States is now English
anyone who lives in France for any in
the American pollutes from France or any
period of time we'll learn how ignorant
in general the French are about the
United States now that's true of every
country you go to there's no reason why
they should know as much about your
countries
even in that country plays a big role of
the country but more striking to me is
the lack of curiosity about the United
States and France
I mean curiosity you haven't opened the
hood of a car I just want to figure out
how does it work and that's Ritter I
mean I think it's striking to me just to
compare them people young French people
to young Germans or Italians or French
in general the Germans Italians and
French visit the United States and early
age it's part of their you know who you
know the part of their ticket back to
punch to claim the States
get on a Greyhound bus across the
country exhibition the Germans are all
it will go to any black church anywhere
to have a real American experience
you taxes that do all that because to
you Germany yet understand America
that's part of what it is to understand
yourself times and and and their English
is excellent the English the Germans and
the Dutch speak better English you meet
you the French do not speak French well
young French people they don't spend a
lot of time with American television
it's getting better because the Internet
but in general is just a striking lack
of curiosity about United strength
States and I think that is given rise to
both a strange screening of
anti-americanism Oh
about us to these as written but also
Street rules Pro Americans that are the
product of the fantasy as well now you
remember the line from Oscar Wilde's it
wants to be earnest pray don't talk to
me about the weather mr. Worthington
whenever people talking out of the
weather
I always feel quite certain evening
something else and that makes me so
nervous I feel when they're talking
about the u.s. they're really talking
about something else and not about feel
existing so I was there for all the ball
and I was also there for these home to
nap and it was an extraordinary moment
for thinking about America
it was also idea phase the moment in
French intellectual culture
it did indeed seem that a 200 year
history had come to an end that a
certain Democratic drama that has pitted
two revolutions against each other in
the 18th century had come to an end with
one model being dominant and the other
having failed we saw the end of an
illusion in his terms and the rise of is
problematic about democracy in Iran few
things and around magazines that was a
bomb and discipline you saw develop a
kind of doctrine about politics in which
the u.s. played a crucial role a central
shin and Kim and Nam there you in an
apocalyptic picture of the rise of
modern democracy and individualism on
the other extreme yet people a hue will
get ski and let more light in
light-hearted tape on American popular
culture changes in fashion the weird
little things we do there in a smoking
legislation it's just odd things that
democracies do and especially in the
United States and I'd say that that was
very instructive for me to see the u.s.
from outside in that way
and through a particular lens but the
fruit of the way I can see that it was
everything revolved around a single
theme which is an amount of Tokyo movie
do mom and put it that there was this
world historical drama that had taken
place
Atlanta Frances from position and but
I'm reading America you were able to
read continues in the future that's
essentially how things work
and it was good to get away from a kind
of more provincial in the US and getting
excited about things people were excited
about academic little practice well the
total drama is still being beat men in
France and I'm more surprised my friends
were writing who've been writing these
things I will curiously remain about the
states
the most obvious thing I understand
America better watch American TV that
America weaves itself through American
television there were no TVs to begin
with and they are unwilling to get their
fingers dirty to pay attention to swim
in the strange time that is America and
the morning me networks would think
about them
the more I could appreciate it will set
in you Nicole
is for me one of the rarest of birds in
France
sometimes I'm genuinely curious and
open-minded of us speaks full of
colonial American English and spent a
lot of time here just observing we
didn't you talks about the weather about
the way and when who talks about the
u.s. is actually still is a difference
when you need to just books
you do get a take on us that is unusual
there's a way which is particularly
American Historians have talked to each
other about the same things in a sense
of distance and perspective and what he
writes Denis is learn from took being
took plays that role in the latest book
but he doesn't stop there his book
seemed to do two things simultaneously
on the one hand he lectures the French
about the way things really are here and
on the other hand he tells us what we
look like from the outside as I said on
the blur to latest book and I meant it
didn't easy sometimes to understand us
better than we understand ourselves yeah
an example of this is the book that I
feel like you know the best and that's
likely to be don't you take money count
let me say a couple words about that
before turning off
what makes that look especially in a
sense of what's special about these
books and their author that please was
published in 1997 and it would seven
guests in the scene not only is a book
about the US but as an intervention in
current French debates about
multiculturalism in which the US example
was being used and misuse it was a time
many people were praising the United
States and what can France us and you
know what can we be as wonderful as they
are others on the other hand were using
the image of the United States to scare
others to say that our multiculturalism
was eroding our sense of citizenship and
if that's what we want
in French republicanism in all of this
so it wasn't as much people weren't
paying attention to the strange
paradoxes and the nature of American
multiculturalism of intentions within
the United States in an American history
about an American visa question in
response Geneva suggested that
multiculturalism is a unique the
American experience with it is unique to
the United States the way it concedes
himself as a regime and it goes to the
heart of matric national self identity
national identity and also the
contradictions in our identity points to
two strains in American political
culture that you know begin rising
before the American economy on the one
hand the tradition of tolerance
especially tolerance of religion in the
early colonies that could be led to a
reaction mainly over the question of
assimilation if America was a new kind
of regime then its own level everyone
had to be with the program and that
meant perhaps I don't believe election
week but also culture
and these two sides of the debate two
different understanding of what America
is about that
keep kept returning at Tennyson by the
end of the 19th and early 20th century
with Louise narration and and now today
the tension between being a civic nation
and an athletic nation is that the
harder it is to be America the point is
to say there is no American model that
the French can argue about a single
American model that they can hold up is
something that's attractive or
frightening rather the United States is
a contest between two principles have to
do with splitting our minds and it looks
at both of these in this book with
sympathy he understands what do to them
try to achieve but also their
limitations and so doing reminded the
French just how complicated these
questions are on one hand on the other
that the French problem is another
and it was time for us to stop talking
about the American example and to pay
more attention to the real challenges
posed by immigration and tolerance in
France today for me it was just an
eye-opening quote about the US and also
about french debates indirectly well in
his recent book religion in America it
doesn't begin without mistake much about
talk about it but again I see it as a
very interesting intervention there's
another crisis these republicanism now
having to do with Islam in France and
again the u.s. being held up as a model
and that's an antique model and at the
end it's based on ignorance there's an
assumption in France that the Protestant
heritage is at war with mean lighten
meant that a religious principle the
claustrum years of war second one
and the two can never mean to race and
Denis goes in a brilliant way that this
just is not a case that both of these
strains are present in our thinking and
our nature's Americans again he's
written an unlikely book and against
again he's managed to sir
my name's Alex I'm thrilled something
great institution the first moment
Charles Taylor distinguished scholar in
residence we had and he created the mama
what you should be residents open to the
students open to the faculty we need to
work but the Lightning Hampshire and
helped out on all sorts of things and
this he intended I think a lot of my
course so he ended up Co teaching the
students with so it was the best
possible type of online scholarship and
then question about and this we now have
14 books in our series this is one of
the absolute first ones is the first one
accepted and gave the whole series some
credibility with the Columbia University
Press and I think
and it's interesting on the question of
friendship and respect I asked him to
write a preface to this second and then
when I heard his dying I wrote a note
saying book I I know you can't and don't
feel under any responsibility to write
down four days after Tommy died
and practice a lot it obviously was one
of the things that he did in the last
two days of his life because that's the
respect he has for speaker thank you so
much that means difficult start after so
in a flattering Cummings but I'm
grateful for how invited me here and in
English and Mark Cummins look at which
are basic not just from this book of
previous thoughts as well and that was
wonderful on his part and also I'm glad
we both can judge it was an unexpected
gift I thought that preface and a great
surprise and so I'm grateful to all of
you
so let me directly talk about other
tensions than the money vote by mark
Lena tensions between that's gonna be
the first part of my talk on our early
narratives of the American national
identity and competing their lives of
the American identity and then secondly
look at the revival of those narratives
of the American identity the 20th and
21st century so whatever I came back to
the United States and so it's and that's
pretty often that's two or three times a
year it's it's always surprising for me
to see how prevalent is religion in
America last summer I was in California
as much talk about Governor Perry's Day
of Prayer Texas called the response in
which at the time he hadn't decided that
we would run for the primaries and a day
of prayer in which the future candidate
declared echoed his love for the Living
Christ their prayer which by definition
could not make a non-christian or even a
Catholic terribly comfortable but that's
Texas for you and as a French political
scientist is written on the origin under
the American Republic actually at the
time of the bicentennial of those who
vote by Martina and look the affinities
between French and there
Oh thought in eighteenth-century I even
wrote once an article called the trade
of Republican ideas between France and
the United States it's always a
difficult coming from France to explain
this exuberant are really just to the
United States and to reconcile it with
with West from an undeniable reality
namely the senator foundation of the
American government a signaler
foundation which by the way it was
greatly admired by the French and to a
certain extent by member of British
observers at the same time so the
challenge then is to explain the
coexistence of what I call us to two
radically different trends in religious
tradition that invites American
politicians to talk openly about their
own faith incites them to defend and
promote religious ideas or symbols in
the public square and on the other
another tradition that insists on the
necessity to preserve the separation of
church and state and the novice class
between let's say openly religious
Republicans and more secular less
obviously religious Democrats of course
that wasn't always the case that has a
lot to do with southern strategy of the
Republican Party which is really
something that
bird shop in 60s particularly rich our
climax under the Carter Administration
so the book is an attempt to explain
competing values and to place those
values in a long historical perspective
and also in a comparative perspective
what matters firm is not religion as an
isolated phenomenon but the uses of
religion by political elites and by its
lecturers in order to create or reinvent
a national identity and national
identities are always difficult to
define because they are at the center of
historical controversies rival
discourses narratives inventions
reconstruction and so on and there's an
added difficulty in United States
because the chronology of events is very
different from that of year perhaps with
the exception of Germany that is to say
I think these trying to John Geering
put it beautifully he says the following
in the United States the constitutional
roof was built before national walls
revolution created a political system a
political regime but to offer century
and similar to solidify the national
walls and so the starting point of the
argument is from a European perspective
there's not one narrative but at least
two rival narratives of American
identity first one call it a crazy story
of a secular republic which had a lot in
common
a friend Republican tradition and which
promotes key principles with which quite
familiar in the idea of equality your
summer tell the people the onion
separation churches they so on it's over
and the idea that our republic is by
definition opposed to monarchy that is
to say there is no divine right power
there's no established church and that's
those are very important thing which are
visible admit if you read the
Declaration of Independence that's what
it's all bad a Republicans which can be
secular
hence the unpopular no she defended by
some American story and I think about my
friend Isaac redneck who wrote is this
important work called the godless
Constitution and then the second
narrative which I called new Puritan or
romantic and I explained why is really
something which became fashionable
little later at the beginning of the
nineteenth century and which in fact
denies the secular nature of the
American government and gives tremendous
importance not so much the founding
fathers who are predominantly Pilgrims
and to the Puritans it's another
creation story which was reinvented late
were early New England but reinvented at
the national level in the nineteenth
century by a number of historian son the
most prominent of them being George
Bancroft with his famous ten volume
history of the United States the first
volume was published in 1934 one year
before prevailed
democracy in America eighteen
18:34 and drop 18:35 first one we were
totally so been destructive of the
secular narrative the first one which
emphasizes sent separation of church and
state and tolerated
it's of course not something not an
American invention but you could read
John Locke about it fine early element
of separation you can leave Roger
Williams also but what's interesting for
me coming from friends is the way
enlightenment philosophers discuss the
periods in general and in North America
and usually in London philosophers saw
the Puritans as zealous as dentists
fanatics including John Locke John Locke
for instance in the letter toleration
attacks the Calvinists
for having used eyesight John Locke
bloody violence to for the execution we
shall survey who has Auburn today now
Geneva II 1553 from there is another
very good example of a philosopher who
find religion in general dangerous
because they should or later lead to
fanaticism and in his friend examine me
nobody bought well tell me dances the
stupidity of fanaticism and of all
Christian Millonarios that called
see speaker and who got there literally
except the book of Revelation and made
for the dimension prediction that a New
Jerusalem would descend from the earth
the result of such analysis
was that Europe was drowned in an ocean
of blood no Cortana
so yeah numerous evidence that the
Puritans are not locked in you it's the
article pure talent
DeRozan simply read young bright
critical as a beacon our famous history
of the two indices which was republished
many times in Europe and in France
around 1780 brain flew into a book about
the colonization of the Americas and of
North America repeated many times and I
never thought when he talks about the
Puritans settlers whether the side drop
on when they accomplished great things
but very quickly says that well the
success was partly due to the help of
local Indians the welcoming presence
puts it of a few savages and yet and
it's great to start by that chocolate
years later objects you know a century
later
Captain John Lovell will murder of local
Indians near Boston the White Mountains
of New Hampshire Island and so another
concludes his section on the Puritans
for the following question
we're in Christians know you were
monsters of extermination and gore and
he sees the Puritans as a very metallic
type of modern variable that
conquistadors that's the way in Europe
we'll talk about key realism and this
harsh criticism of American number of
religious successes of course doesn't
imply that religion was rejected in
general and again if you come back
as a major exception for Volterra and
another of French philosophers and
that's the fragrance record preparation
for scepter Franklin is an ideal utopian
religion it's a religion for
non-religious age and what fascinates
about there is that in preference that
you have a religion a government without
priests with that sacrament with that
communion and anti-capitalism and
praises that and started a tradition all
the French visitors who go to North
America well come of tearing their
pocketbook try to meet crackers in
Philadelphia and some will be
enthusiastic about what they see others
will be disappointed depending on the
time they visit but basically we come
back then to this first Center narrative
American identity I think it's really at
the heart of a very important dialogue
we forgotten I have company for us that
took place between the successor of
dubrow's encyclopedia devenir published
in a security method eat in between 1784
and 1786 it's racism in American Frank
remember that involved they were near
one side is knew it secretly 14 articles
on the United States one per state was
one
lizard doesn't need and medicine
Jefferson are the other side and with a
great fascination for Jefferson's bill
for establishing religious freedom which
was probably no drafted early in 1777
but did not become law in Virginia until
1786 thanks to the very active lobbying
of Medicine and it's a law that is a
purpose of the law to disestablish the
everyday Church to abolish all religious
all religions to make sure that no tax
is collected for church or for a school
of religious school that bill was
immediately transmitted the earth
America's transmitted to French public
that seor in Davinia's encyclopedia
full translation and was discussed three
years before the French Revolution it
was a discussion about the importance of
separation of church and state in
Virginia and Virginia was presented as
common Universal model for a revolution
to come and a secularism to come and
given in by the way practicing young
person he was the century of Monsieur to
choose the name of the weasel 16th
brother and I was a lawyer by training
well a few survived the French
Revolution was that any train lived in
United States before before it went back
to France a name I think was in a
consulate or elected official under the
Napoleon
so this sauce is franco-american
dialogue you find the same interesting
dialog between of radical Whigs in
Britain and American families and I'll
give you one example you all know about
Tom Paine but less well-known is the
case of James Berger
James birth is a radical wig the author
of a book called Kratos - volume of
estimates and falling to a creek oh
that's published in 1767 his dedicated
quote to the good people of Britain of
the year of the 20th century so it's an
utopia from future age and by the way
it's a classic thing to do when you
write it you talk about one way for you
to criticize a government without being
penalized for criticizing the monarch
because you place that in a distant
future and in fact it's a deconstruction
systematic deconstruction of the British
monarchy and bird invents the phrase law
of separation in that time book second
book any tax breaks and the lips mongrel
spiritual temporal secular and
ecclesiastical establishment of the
monarchy and asked for privatization of
church functions calls for the abolition
of the test Act which will not be
abolished in Britain until if I'm not
mistaken
nineteen
I and ask the good people of Britain of
the 20th century could build an
impenetrable wall separation between
things sacred and so now we know and
drives bags
breaking dog legal historian as
demonstrated that in fact Trudeau had
been read by Jefferson Jefferson owned
the work and probably found is
inspiration for the famous Jefferson
letter to the Baptist community of
Denver and probably found this
especially in gentlemen so now when we
consider the second nuclear narrative of
American identity which I call new
Puritan or romantic let me explain what
I mean by that now in the nineteenth
century
of course the consensus among
intellectuals that the french revolution
fatal terror and as ended in the
disaster and it's a time and that's why
i call it romantic
when tradition religious values
religious emotions are being
rediscovered and praised and also
there's a passion for medieval studies
potent quote ancestors great ancestors a
unit pretty evolved past and great the
goals assassins the germanic tribes of
Germany of course are all praised and
honored and there's a new historical
register of graphic fashion that
developed and it's really the idea that
in order to understand the natural
identity
to learn yet to consider to identify the
character of the people or the spirit of
the people that's what Bancroft cities
so also Antonio cities are for instance
when he says typical example this
nursery ah he says quote democracy in
America the character of our nation is
contained in its article music wrote in
a matter of speaking cyst revealed the
whole man already lies swelled in his
cradle and that's a brightening chapter
to democracy in America entitled on the
point of departure and its importance
for future Americans so character the
spirit of a nation that's where it
starts and the German would say the both
duyst's it's the same as the same many
and to be found in offending people and
that's the heart of a romantic
imagination think of herder
think of the Schlegel Brothers think of
officiating in France think of a zoo in
the United States think of John Quincy
Adams Daniel Webster and of course
George Bancroft and never forget that
George Bancroft
who was a kind of boy genius he
graduated from Harvard at age fourteen
that was sent to Germany from 1818 to
1822 he studied a gun against that in
Berlin by mark two courses from plum on
church history courses from voeckler
Tacitus the weather we discovered the
importance of Germania
romantic tribes possibly have a taste
for liberty freedom
he studied theology which linebacker
history here or was a disciple of a
heard and so forth
so in the United States if you look at
the origin and raise a question who
represents best the spirit of the
American people both guys from the
American people so difficult question
indeed because Tocqueville and Bancroft
admit that the colonization started in
Virginia not in North not in doing that
but Virginia is not a good case
motivation was not religious those
people who came to Virginia where gold
diggers and I'm not honorable for a
trophy LeBron scribble ISM undisciplined
men and if you break it up American
Indians weren't you left with the New
England the Pilgrims and the Puritans
and we'd argue that Bancroft did for
America but testers have done from the
Germans it would rehabilitation rains
mocked and denigrated by enlightenment
philosophers and I should add superbly
ignored by the founding fathers there's
not a single reference to the Puritans
in the Federalist Papers from Amundsen
so then crop marks the triumph of New
England of historiography and bankers
arguments of really really is that the
character of Pilgrim shaped the new
American nationality and the climax of
course of the narrative that's
cabin where an iSight bancroft humanity
recovers its rights and birth of
constitutional Liberty takes place now
it's a new narrative which you find
developed almost exactly the same term
in intervals democracy in America one
knew the other read the script I mean
this was the age and it's also
providential conception of American
history decided that they are kind of
marvelous continuity from Luther and
Calvin to the Puritans of New England
where they improve notion of Liberty
that develops in man and pops out as a
modern Republic and quote from Bancroft
the Puritans planted on the soil of a
virgin country quote the seminal
principles of Republican freedom and
independence England and Torvill would
say very much the same looking up they
make a compact that insight but without
the references to the king loyalty to
the king which would give it a less
Republican appearance so Tobias forties
kind of tactical and he compares that to
it's almost like the genuine thoughtful
contract says prevailing the note that
was discovered recently social contract
in the lines dragged five was so now of
course there are a number modern
historians specialists of New England
history today that have questioned the
centrality of the Mayflower Compact
which in fact was very much an act of
circumstance designed to prevent a near
mutiny aboard the Mayflower so basically
what we have is advocates of this mill
Cureton narrative that will create work
very hard to create a new cult of
ancestors symbolizing the genius of the
American people and Bancroft will set
the end of all in one of the history
unite a civil suit limiting of the
pilgrims at Plymouth and at the stage
instead of pilgrims really displace the
family fathers now let me examine I'm
going to skip the part that's about the
19th century early 20th century my work
and let's exactly right Paul that's the
second half of my talk the revival of
both the second secular narrative on the
one hand and the Puritan narrative in
the late 20th century 21st century now
in the 20th century the secular
narrative which was defender / Jefferson
and others was rediscovered by
progressive
justices of the Supreme Court and I
would argue that this paradigm still
works more on us today in the Supreme
Court
despite numerous attempt to break down
the law separation between church and
state and a classic decision the Everson
decision of 1947 the best illustration
of this revival for tourism because
number one it applies the Establishment
Clause of the First Amendment to all the
states
so through the doctrine of incorporation
and certainly it is based on a very
interesting historical research
methodology a rereading of Jefferson's
letter to the Baptist of Dan URI and
it's a decision where the Justice black
concludes his opinion for the following
words the First Amendment has erected
the role of the truth between church and
state but wall was behind impregnable
who would not accept the slightest
breach end quote now the reality may be
different and in fact if you look more
carefully at that opinion which is about
financing public financing transmission
of students due to Catholic schools in
fact the opinion was that this was not a
contradiction that was not evaluated by
the Establishment Clause but that's
beside the point
what's interesting is the rediscovery of
the metaphor by justice black and why is
that so again as an historian if you
look at the way he proceeds what's
fascinating is that he uses case law and
there are not too many growing cases
dealing with religious of free exercise
or Establishment Clause but one case
that's important for just as bad he's
the Reynolds decision of 1879 the
decision about a federal law that
criminalizes polygamy at the time in the
mornings were still in the territory
were trying to preserve traditional
Phillippe
and the court's decision was about no
religion is not not acceptable and
what's interesting is that that other
case Reynolds was written by Justice
wait
and why was wait there are wonderful
ethics in this case where you find the
full text of the bill and religious
freedom by Jefferson medicines writings
that the famous letter to the Danbury
Baptist community so the key question
from start over but why this passion for
early or late 18th century text than
having forgotten and the response which
is suggested by price bag is the form
and it happened that weight lived in the
neighborhood that was such in what in DC
is never in fact was George Bancroft and
George Bancroft fed him with all
historical documents that have been
printed or that creatures but
rediscovered and so given that
information and in fact we know that
because Wade st. is famous neighbor for
the transmission of quote historical
facts that helping decide the case so
today I would argue that the true
guardians of the wall separation between
church and state are federal judges and
justices of the Supreme Court especially
progressive justices but of course the
jurisprudence has evolved and you have
what I would call separatist on one leg
lawyers prefer for than separation lists
and anti separate
detail here but basically what's the
viewpoint of the separatist is that when
you have a number of classic decisions
the ban on school prayers public school
the ban on the display of a Christmas
nativity scene in the public square the
ban on the display of Ten Commandments
in the courthouse or in classrooms all
those are still some of which are quite
recent decision demonstrated commitment
through the separation of Trenton state
and the key reasoning often involved
there is principal government are
traveling and the idea that which is
often cited I think justice Souter for
instance in in a recent case but it's
it's an opinion that sites and it's
often cited that it's originally and
being my justice O'Connor which is that
it religious display whatever its nature
whether it's across prayer tape tablets
for the Tenth Amendment those religious
display cannot be tolerated in the
public space if court they send a
message to normative adherence that they
are outsiders not full members of the
political community and an accompanying
message to adherence that they are
insiders favored members which means
what it means that there's no prefer
religion
United States or for that matter no
predominant religion in the United
States citizenship is perceived as
all-inclusive and every religious faith
has its place including pagan religion
including centuriata the famous decision
by Supreme Court called the Church of
Lukumi babalu Pi which tolerates animal
sacrifices in Florida even though that
violates the local ordinance that
prohibits cruelty to animals so
basically every religion is respectable
and non-religion is also respectable and
then let's examine the revival of the
Neo Kirk narrative excited revival in
the courts in political science and in
mainstream politics in the courts that
revive all you find it with conservative
justices first late Justice Rehnquist
and today probably Justice Thomas and
Scalia and their position with is that
of an anti severance they don't believe
in the wall separation and they'd rather
get rid of the jettison there
Jefferson's medical in that position the
United States is a Christian nation or
at least a nation that is built on
Christian principles and the founding
father - despite you start the litigants
I would argue are no different from the
pilgrims they believe in God they were
motivated by a Christian principle they
believed in a crystallized political
morality and are ranked whispers and
writes that the wall separation between
church and state is a metaphor based on
that history a metaphor which has proved
useless as a guy
judging that should be frankly abandoned
that's Wallis versus Geoffrey
and like most separatist he read quit
trying to collapse American history
press trans great I want to quote from
him from a decision that it's called
district of Benton 1963 kids when he
writes strength we're driving history
well the fact that the founding fathers
believed devotedly that there was a God
and the rights of man are rooted in him
is clearly evidence in their writings
from the Mayflower Compact to the
Constitution itself and quote so as it
is collapsing so many many years of
American history into one as the
Protestant thinking and Lightman thought
were one of the same as if the jealous
God of the Old Testament was the same
thing as a creator of the Declaration of
Independence but remember that the god
of the direct declare independence is is
not a jealous gun Walter burns has shown
that beautifully in the book called
making Patriots the creators there is
rights but that disappears he doesn't
condense doesn't punish is not an Old
Testament God it's the sovereign people
who have rights defend their rights and
and and make
and we define them what kind of God well
who knows that who cares since in the
Republican form of government can be
without God has Jefferson's venison
seasoned notes in Virginia which was
translated into fraction and why they
read in France as well of semester like
FTP and said the following quote doesn't
mean no injury to say there are 20
guards of no God neither picks my pocket
no breaks my leg and remember the
Jeffersonian spare time he's elected
president what is it you are cuts and
pastes takes the gospel rewrite the
Gospels in something which will be
become known as the Jefferson Bible and
it cuts out everything that's there with
miracles
with the Resurrection and the end of the
Jefferson Bible is the following quote
and Joseph rolled a great stone to the
door of the sepulchre and depart end of
Jackson's Bible which was published by
late in 1895 and republished by the
Congress and night to go for at that
time the Congress would give a free copy
of Jefferson's Bible to every new
elected member of Congress I'm afraid
that's not being done today
now in political science that the
example of the revival of this narrative
you find that a good example is in the
let work of Professor Samuel Huntington
in the book called
who are we which is read about the
American identity subtitle the
challenges to America's national
identity it's a book that came out 2004
and very much like when Chris Huntington
refuses to make a peer cut distinction
between Puritan history and period of
family fathers for him it's it's in a
way it's one of the same which is a way
of diminishing the importance of the
founding fathers and increasing the
importance of the Puritan of experience
in a good resilient fashion and say this
is why friends the Huntington argues
that what the American creed is the
unique reader of sending Protestant
culture or that admits that the Cree has
some element of and enlightenment
cultures but immediately after those
ideas found receptive ground in the
Anglo Protestant culture already existed
in America for over a century and
conclude support religion has been still
his central perhaps this central element
American identity and that's why by the
Brady heart when he looks at spinnings
the immigration of the new migrants
Latinos for him their values do not fit
he ever decreed that cannot be
assimilated they are not compatible the
American creed the fact that has been
challenged by Fukuyama's wonderful
article Fujiyama brought about hunting
it's going to point where's the
Protestant ethic today it's probably the
immigrant worker works much harder than
natives and that's where you find the
Protestant but also at the Huntington's
forgot how difficult was the integration
of Irish Catholics Italian Catholics in
the United States and that's why I have
a chapter on the Bible Wars and the
point of the chapter of our awards 19th
centuries to show them for government
how violent have instructed how vicious
where the conflict between Protestants
and Catholic innocent and migrants in
the 19th century and it took quite a
while
- to be silly and thirdly revival of new
Puritan narrative of course you finding
- this progress of a Michele Bachmann
statement can dr. Perry statement about
the importance of of Christianity it's
not a new phenomenon hoc committee when
he was a candidate in 2008 said in one
of the primary study wanted to
crystallize the Constitution in
rewriting the preamble of the
Constitution so and there are things are
taking place for instance Jeff Rosen
recently showed in a breaking article
that the influence of Willard clione
scousers strange book the five thousand
lead 28:28 ideas that changed the world
that book was published in 1981 and that
book is popularized by Glenn Beck on the
circle University which you can see
Friday Friday night and is a key
source of information for seminars that
they offered today in Washington DC
seminars are offered by the National
Center for transpeople studies which are
tended by elected member of the Congress
and staff members of the Congress and
the point of the seminars is to
demonstrate the Christian the nature of
the American government
now for those rationed scouser uses I
arguments which are called hair
guarantee protect herder
romantic offer the Germany he advocated
for instance a return to set some
liberties he praises the superiority of
English accent thought and it's like
reading bankrupt again but a very
simplified simplistic Bancroft written
again kind of providential reading of
American history with an implicit
hierarchy of races but living a further
I believe that the revival and they'll
here at the narrative has a lot to do
with the Southern Strategy of the
Republican Party which which with the
climax under the cottage Carter
demonstration another time when if you
looked at this source the origin of the
moral majority which will help Reagan's
election and you look at the key
organizer not so much for well but the
organizers right here the key struggle
at the time had locked nerd with a
Christian with the Christian academies
now the prison academies were private
schools that were developed in the south
to resist the desegregation that had
been inaugurated by by legal decision
but also by the Civil Rights Act and
Carter had made it clear that he would
continue to Christian academies would
not be free of tax and it's at this
point that the fundamentalist right
which was not politically organized
became really organized and became the
world majority and so once eventually
called my maternity ventricles were
given the prominent place in the
Republican Party well it was clear that
relieved
values traditional family values would
become central to the platform of the
other Grand Old Party transformation and
of course with huge electoral
consequences and I would give a
prominent place to what I call the
revival of The New Yorker paradigm so
let me conclude now looking back to
beginning a French perception of
religion in America why they've changed
the earth and market I said very very
nicely that it's kind of lack of
curiosity about the United States and
France more today that mean the 18th
century by the way surprisingly I mean
there's less distance between the
continents and less and yet we seem to
not understand the United States as well
as we need to be its incentive I think
part of the problem is the inability of
the French can understand evangelicalism
as if the first the second Great Divide
will have never existed a part of the
reason is not that friends is not a
secular society but I think it has
preserved the rest from Catholic culture
in a secular environment and this
Catholic culture is based on respect for
order high rocky discipline based on
fear of awkwardly expressed religious
emotions fear also tremendous
competition fear of religious
entrepreneurship which makes it very
difficult for French commentators to
explain the rise of revenge legal
battles it's not a new phenomena tick to
reveal totally
had a nice abstract concept of the term
name had a real problem dealing with
eventually though he attended a number
of Kent meetings in the mid 19th century
that's described not in democracy in
America where the father tax and we know
that when Tokyo describes and kept
meeting he writes like Trump and
expresses real fear about the future of
American democracy fear based on a dual
threat a few skepticism over one hand
that could lead to shock ilysm that's
exactly an undisciplined religion that
could lead to Anika and so it deploys
that priority it kind of really just
deicide turbulent we do cement to the
position approves and vote insect in
America and then it has a solution
which is a kind of modernized Catholic
Church that could be the best Church for
very kind of sex but the only French
thinker got a positive view of
evangelicalism is Mahaska radiates a
student talk about fact sensing more an
economist and you came to America his
letters were published two years after
Tocqueville 1836 but it's not as about
no less somebody you know and he was
relative pressed by camp meetings and
why because the important place that was
given to women because he notes that
after all women are not political
participant they are not involved daily
politics they don't vote but they are
very much present at all the levels that
in the hierarchy of the evangelical
sects that he can observe and he
concludes that looking at there are full
participants in Methodist and Baptist
revivals and he concludes that well
that's probably where real democracy is
at work in religious minute now today
the very recent recent French receptions
are following now they have afraid that
when we do not understand American
politics we use the easy stereotyped
easy reflection that are often they're
all Puritans
no wonder to do this that and that's
terrified so well entrenched that by
1925 persons when start visits the
United States and Simone de Beauvoir not
together one after
they come out with the same reflection
that indeed young Americans are credibly
Puritan and they both even claim that
their peers in the NSP percent